si tu ne dis pas qu edith femme qui va
chercher voix haut perchée fayette
talons plume et froufrous voilà les
seules représentations de
l'homosexualité à la télé dans les
années 50 60
charpy ni et est ouvertement homosexuel
mais tolérée car appartenant au monde du
spectacle
tout comme colette mars qui chantait la
garçonne
[Musique]
mais dans les années 70 alors que
l'homosexualité est encore considéré
comme un fléau social selon la loi
française est aussi catégorisé comme une
maladie mentale selon l' oms certains
homos ne veulent plus se cacher et la
télévision devient un outil de
revendications
nous sommes à côté de vous parmi vous
les homosexuels sont dans votre famille
sont dans votre milieu de travail sont
dans votre église sont dans notre
syndicat sont dans votre parti politique
andré beaudry fondateur de l'une des
premières associations homosexuelles
s'expriment pendant 15 minutes à la
télévision et interroge un journaliste
mais aussi un prêtre condamné quelques
appâts ce kit audio sexuel chez tu
dribbles une entame
c'est une injustice grave andré beaudry
n'est pas le seul dans les années
soixante dix partout en france des
associations sont fondées pour demander
plus de justice d'égalité mais aussi
dénoncé les discriminations et leur
discours est relayée à la télévision
contient un problème sur un cassage de
gueule ou syrte soit à un licenciement
sous une expulsion d'appartement c'est
alerter l'opinion publique sensibiliser
les gens à toutes ses formes de
répression qui n'ont pratiquement pas de
justification réelle disneyland et dont
il doit tout à fait dépasser début des
années 80 la france est à la veille
d'une élection présidentielle et pour la
première fois les homosexuels sortent
dans la rue pour la gay pride est les
caméras les accompagnent le pavé de
paris a connu cet après-midi la plus
importante manifestation en faveur de la
liberté de l'homosexualité qui ait
jamais eu lieu en france homosexuels et
lesbiennes vous êtes concernés par
l'élection présidentielle
ce tract circulait parmi les quelques
5000 participants à la marche conduisant
de la mutualité au centre pompidou les
homosexuels réclament aux candidats un
recours légal
lorsqu'ils sont victimes de la
discrimination les lois discriminantes
datant de vichy seront abolis en 1982
mais les réjouissances seront de courte
durée car au début des années 80 un
fléau fait son apparition le sida une
particularité elle n'atteint que les
homosexuels mâles une nouvelle chape de
plomb s'abat alors sur les homosexuels
dans les médias ils seront reléguées aux
pages santé des jt
il faudra attendre les années 90 et le
débat sur le pacs pour que de nouveaux
l'homosexualité redevienne un sujet
d'égalité des droits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]